Ngày hôm 12, tên thủ tưởng pháp SBC lệ Cóc Ngu đã chính thức gặp trước,
khẳng định thuốc đệ những thay đổi cạnh bản không chia ở hình thức.
Mà cả tròn lỗi dùng truy sách,
tâm thơ dân mạnh không có con đường nào là bất khả thị để đuôi nước pháp vừa qua cuộc của bạm chí chị hệ này.
Chồng bà pháp biểu hành gọi chưa đánh nào phút.
Ông định có cây giao gọi sự kiếm chế, chứ định chẳng bắt ổn và cuộc hạm chí chị.
Mà đất nước năng phà đưa mắt.
Tùng thời cắm kết sẽ sáng tạo hơn, giống túc hơn tròn kế là việc về khai đổi lập.
Tùng thời khẳng định sẽ xâm tiếp sức với các lực lộ triển trọng ngày tới.
Tình thủ tưởng lệ các nguy cộng dân mạnh,
mong muốn chấm rất tình trạng trên lệ chữa đời sọ triển.
Bà nơi sọc tụi tế,
có đầy là vấn đề đã lo ngại và càng báo không thể đề tìm trọng này.
Giao dài mạnh mạnh.
Ông lệ có nguy nhập trước trường với thời điểm đúng pháp các cuộc biểu tình của mọi lớn.
Chên khắp nước pháp,
cũng ngay ông đã chữ tập của gặp với nội khác.
Nếu thào lất về các giảm quyết là sống cụ tình này.